cet été on a vu des milliers de
personnes surtout des haïtiens arrivés
ici à la frontière entre le canada et
les états unis
combien pourront réellement rester est
ce que certains seront expulsés on ne
guérit
[Musique]
lorsque les gens arrivent ici ils
remplissent ce qu'on appelle une demande
d'asile est à l'heure actuelle ça prend
au moins six mois avant d'être traités
historiquement les demandes d'asile ou
de réfugiés la communauté haïtienne ont
approuvé à peu près 50%
nous nous sommes donc basé sur les
données de 2013 à 2017 pour vérifier si
c'est vrai qu'un demandeur d'asile sur
deux est refusé lorsqu'il est originaire
d'haïti en fait 54 % d'entre eux sont
refusés lors de la première étape
venir au canada n'est pas un billet
automatique d'entrée il ya tous ceux qui
obtiennent gain de cause lors de la
deuxième étape lorsqu'ils font appel
et lors de la troisième étape la cour
fédérale pour laquelle il n'y a pas de
statistiques
alors quand les politiciens et les
fonctionnaires disent qu'un demandeur
d'asile haïtiens sur deux est refusé ils
n'ont dans les faits qu'une partie de
l'information en mec
maintenant est ce que ceux qui sont
refusés sont expulsés
entre 2004 et 2007 il y avait pas
d'expulsion vers haïti parce que la
situation là bas est instable
par contre en 2016 100 personnes ont été
expulsées vers lille puis en 2017
il y en a eu 474 on ne sait pas dans
quelle proportion les gens qui sont
arrivés ici cet été seront expulsés
parce que vous l'aurez compris leurs
dossiers n'ont pas encore été traités si
vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
tribune
[Musique]